you
got to meet taylor swift and it was kind
of a pivotal moment in your life can you
tell us a little bit about that i'm
about a year into nashville
my life is crumbling at the scene i mean
i first weekend i moved to nashville
house is broken in two it's just one
thing after the other and at this moment
i called my sister that morning and i
said i have no clue
what i'm doing out here and that day
taylor swift was driving by i was
leaving work and i happened to be
wearing a taylor swift tour t-shirt and
she saw me standing like on the side of
the road pulled her car over and was
like
i love your shirt so much and it was
just like such a
eye-opening moment for me and
i quit my job i quit school and i was
like i don't know what to do
but i'm going to figure out how to do
this
and figure it out she has her song just
about over you is a crossover hit while
thick thighs has become an inspiring
anthem
[Applause]
you know we don't see a whole lot of
country songs celebrating body
positivity why is that so important for
you
i want to inspire other people you know
trying to get into country music like
hey listen like you can be a curvy girl
and own that and you don't have to look
like everybody else or
just fit into a box i don't want to fit
into a box
so this song is just really important
for me um and it's been really really
awesome to see how the fans connect to
it who would be your dream collaboration
if you could work with any artist and
collaborate on a song together i would
love to do something with freaking luke
combs but then on the other hand i would
love to do something with lizzo i mean
hell if dolly parton called me i'd say
dolly are you listening we could just
write a song called like big boobs and
big hair and big boobs like
let's go
[Music]